[Music]
the city of boston has many great
attributes but the treasure of the north
end is its outstanding italian food
served at over 150 italian restaurants
the first fine dining establishment in
this neighborhood was davide which
opened in 1982. david back in the heyday
it was the number one italian restaurant
in boston it was incredible there was
always a line at the door what's the
name if you didn't make reservations
three weeks in advance you could not get
in in 1997 then matrid frank and his
brother anthony fulfilled the dream by
purchasing davide at the height of its
popularity
this is amazing when we bought the
restaurants we were making money i felt
like we hit a gold mine are they liking
the chicken special they're liking it
i'm working with frankie and my life is
wonderful
the restaurant started off strong but
within the first couple years frank
found out that anthony was embezzling
money i went into the account whenever i
needed money i would if i had access i
would take money to you know buy
painkillers whatever
he was addicted to painkillers heroin
he's been in detox in jail he's out of
jail the responsibility of keeping
anything open cause i was
my struggles basically
there was no one else there to help it's
3 30 you got to get ready for dinner
it's definitely gonna get [ __ ] anyways
tonight no you're not when anthony left
frank gave up
he's broken mentally and physically oh
my god
can't work like this
and little by little
it's broken a restaurant
since i've been back i am
not the same person hi good evening i'm
in recovery i'm doing well
those days are behind me i'm here i'm
responsible and i'm making the
restaurant a priority right this way
let's forget about the past and move on
and i don't think he has i don't think
he can shut the [ __ ] up take the food
that's up in the window and come back so
i ask
go away
but at the same time he should take some
responsibility of giving up and not
putting the whole blame on me because of
what i did anthony don't take the wrong
stuff i'll kill you
right now my relationship with anthony
is not at its best this is it
you know he has no more chances it's all
over do [ __ ] hot water get the [ __ ]
out don't waste my time
blankie will not listen to me hey mohawk
this is your tape get the [ __ ] out of
here really
it's all you know just turret and
spiteful oh my god anthony
why don't you go kill yourself
i think that frankie
has a lot of pent up anger and
resentment towards anthony
if it can't be put aside i really can't
see the restaurant succeeding
it's killing them
we need help extremely badly because
we've been living month to month are we
going to be able to take checks next
week
if we close the door tomorrow we would
be out of a million dollars
[Music]
frankie and me always have the conflict
that's why chef ramsay i think is the
answer to help us
if things don't turn around we walk
closer doors
all right the only way to understand
boston properly is jump on one of these
trolleys because those guys have really
got their fingers on the pulse
morning welcome aboard good to see you
good to see you teddy ted
roy how are you i'm very good thank you
where are you heading um north end
please one of my favorite places you
ever heard of the russians every day
well it's funny to say that it's on our
tour room we drive by it probably four
times a day and i don't know anybody
that's really ever gone that's not good
news it's not great news
there's so many restaurants in boston
and we recommend many of them and i
don't know a driver that really
recommends davey day unbelievable
wish me luck
good luck and happy day nice to see you
guys
debbie d
down below
whoa
hello how are you farrell how are you
very good nice to meet you good to see
you then you just walden anthony gordon
ramsay good to see you buddy you are the
i wanted the owners one of them one of
them my brother frank okay great kitchen
what a quiet new place and how long have
you earned it uh 1997. what was the last
thing you changed here we did the books
over and we um took the wallpaper off we
haven't changed as much with the times i
believe time moved on and frankie stayed
right in 1997 and uh he won't change
because they just
gave up that's simple let's get
everybody together and have a proper
start meeting yeah that's good thanks
anthony
hello hi maria thank you my mother oh
wow okay you work here as well she keeps
the peace she's the negotiator
and this is i'm deborah
who
okay great
frank frank good to see you buddy and
frank is your big brother yes
fantastic hi i'm kim i'm frank's wife
frank's wife brilliant take a seat
please
first of all let's find out the truth
how long has it been slow
at least a good three years and you're
in the kitchen you cook
my job was in the dining room all my
life i ran the restaurant in the kitchen
i learned i picked up how did you buy it
my mother gave me the money and me and
my brother and they're buying it
together okay so it's literally a 50 50
business everything's supposed to be 55
right what does that mean help me out
anthony has been in and out of the
restaurant over the 13 years
[Music]
what happened
i know i'm i hooked on painkillers i
took money got in trouble went to jail
the whole nine yards
i worked this seven days a week by
myself
frankie got left with the whole [ __ ] it
got to him got depressed he got burnt
out money went down every year naturally
i did damage to the business but you
cannot get over the past if you can't
put the pass behind you we can't go on
when you've been burned six times it's
hard to say yeah okay that's in the past
anthony is trying to make amends
everything he's done is being criticized
every little thing
is being nitpicked he's because of the
past because of the past
you know everything is anthony anthony i
think he doesn't take any blame for
anything that happened anyway is that
right
it was for me to blame i was gone the
business it was like abandoned
and nothing was done anthony you've
ruined the business
you've destroyed me
i never want to be in a restaurant by
myself
i mean come on i'm mad i'm pissed i'll
[ __ ] tell you to go [ __ ] yourself for
the [ __ ] you put me through oh my
god fine
anthony never apologize never it's like
don't you understand what you've done
you put me in the position i am now but
i like to [ __ ] beat him up here's the
problem i think
he doesn't respect me for anything
because the past everything and i don't
respect him because i think he laid down
and [ __ ] died
wow
minutes of his arrival chef ramsay was
confronted with the bad blood that
exists between the two brothers anthony
you've ruined the business and i don't
respect him because i think he laid down
and [ __ ] died and while his
relationship with anthony is at the
breaking point frank wants to prove that
his cooking skills have not suffered
thank you and this is andrew andrew
thank you andrew recommendations there
isn't a bad thing on the menu caesar
salad's made right in the dining room
from travis yep okay good nice there is
great potential here we just need
someone like gordon ramsay to come in
because the relationship between frank
and anthony is kind of sabotaging the
restaurant all the pastors he and me
that's a big positive all the pastors
handmade yeah all here made that's
incredible
let's start off with el vontini
yeah sure gotta go for the season salad
table side i love that idea
and the fresh lobster ravioli all right
the wreckage i'll go for that as well i
want to see as much as i can and travel
across italy
yeah brilliant yep i hope so
how's the food i think you can call it
trying to push it out when the
attitude's there when he wants to huh
how was frank 47 47. he looks older than
that
stress
jeez
what's he having let's start with the
invotini don't talk to me just write it
down all right
i don't like talking to nobody
i'm nervous but like at the same time i
was like come on bring the test on i
know i could pass i'm not blowing my own
smoke on my ass but that food is good
let's pay the season anybody got the
season going
brilliant table side caesar in the north
end of boston right yep are you going
right to the very basics you got an egg
yolk there as well egg yolk
anchovies
wow who would ever thought i'd be making
a caesar for gordon ramsay
[Music]
i love doing the caesar salad so i put a
lot of enthusiasm into it
[Music]
and
okay great thank you very good
[Music]
have you just washed that salad
yes you just washed it there
because it's soaking
wet so all the dressings just run off it
because the lettuce is soaking wet to
dress a sea salad the salad has to be
crisp but dry
so you've made all that
freaking work for nothing
oh my god eight minutes for nothing
[Music]
kevin think he's gonna like the food i
think so
frank is so defeated right now that he's
lost the confidence in himself as a chef
and
in his abilities the eggplant is in the
window when they get uh andrew
the addiction what was it painkillers
painkillers
oh sees heroin
heroin
really never been in trouble with the
law before that
first time happened to be the fed how
long did you spend inside almost four
years have you been clean for how long
now almost two years that's fantastic
yeah two years clean
it yeah it's nice
here we have the eggplant the voltini de
molenzano
thank you
strange
mhm
hasn't been fried or cooked long enough
not
yeah
it's pretty spongy and horrible
are they frozen no no that's fresh when
were they done
this morning ready
will you just check if that was done
this morning because it tastes like it
was done last week that's all for me
thank you frank
what said this was spongy
what was it
what were they when were they made
you asked me if they were frozen they
said no no three weeks ago
yeah there's a patch of freezer i don't
make it too hard every day
[Music]
i'll go tell them
i can't make eggplant to all that that's
impossible i don't have time you
unless she has a new message i don't
know about his mecca's gonna be gonna
get in here at 11 in the morning
that's what the method is fine well it's
impossible to be here 11 in the morning
no it's not frank frank is a very lazy
cook he doesn't even fry the eggplants
anymore my mother and father end up
frying it
ridiculous
i'm like made yesterday it was actually
made three weeks ago
yep
three weeks ago
yep that's disgusting do you go grocery
shopping three weeks
in advance before you're gonna eat the
stuff no
all right give me a pen i need to keep
score
it's one down one eight plants not good
well off the rabbit that should be fine
what's next a little cereal
and were these made yesterday
i'll make sure i get a date on that
why is that
looks like a good
some of the lobster ravioli made i don't
know the manufacturer does that they are
not homemade
i definitely feel
dumb
you know here i am telling people all
the pastas are handmade
because that's what frank told me
i feel betrayed and my own boss
that's it's not right
that's nasty
the lobster ravioli is store-bought
so it's not fresh no
hold on hold on we're backtracking now
fresh pasta every day all the pasta has
been made yeah all handmade i thought
they were made fresh
why would you have to store bought
that's gross you can never say to frank
frank why didn't the pastors hear me why
don't you come in earlier and make
pastas so i hope that you can get
through to him because he is a good chef
but is he a passionate chef
no no
wow
geez okay um thank you andrew
you say you liked it you didn't like it
you hated the lobster ravioli suck it
down like nothing
i really want to freeze the guy i know
he's gonna complain
i mean come on at least like tell me if
the sauce was good i mean that's all i
asked she didn't like this then like
what the [ __ ] i'm busting again
she's gotta like something kalim uh-huh
just served in a garlic a rosemary crust
and a barrel of red wine sauce bon
potato thank you
what kind of crust is that
rosemary rosemary
it's burnt
it's burnt and bitter when garlic burns
it goes bitter guy can't even taste lamb
i felt embarrassed by some of the dishes
that came out
wow and again passion gone anthony take
me to the kitchen please i'm gonna have
a word with frank
i definitely think we're squealed
okay let's start i sat down i got told
the pasta's fresh
i got excited it's homemade and it's
it's coming from the heart
all of a sudden you got this ravioli
lobster that's store bought
it was horrible but how was the sauce
a [ __ ] about the sauce
the filling is the magic whether it's a
ravioli or tortellini it's the filling
you get excited about
the eggplant but that was a disaster
spongy bitter undercoat and then i got
told it was three weeks ago
embarrassing i mean it's really
embarrassing you can't make fresh food
and freeze it and charge money to
running a [ __ ] business if you can't
be bothered to cook fresh food what do
you want me to do
wave your magic wand and turn this place
around come on
it's just what i do i don't know how to
do any better that's not why you could
do much better or do you want to do
better
that's the big question
i'm gonna get some fresh air i'll be
back later yeah
unbelievable
13 years i've been here chef ramsay
tasting a manual was like the worst
experience i've ever had
[Music]
yeah but you can't be begging for a
compliment frankie that's a thank you
for complimenting i don't care at the
end oh he's like something frankie
thinks he knows everything he's not
gonna hear from anyone you'll need help
he may say [ __ ] ramsay too i don't know
it comes down to us being here or not
being here frank you know it i know it
it's not news you have someone here
willing to help you
do you want to learn from them dead
seriously dead seriously
i don't know well you have to make a
decision today
upset after chef ramsay's harsh critique
of his dishes do you want to do this i
don't know
frank is not only questioning the future
of davide but his own
[Music]
mentally when i'm out the restaurant is
total frustration because there's so
many bad old memories
where's frank hi there there christ we
got down there little booth
i'm thinking come on
did you sit down on your ass to think
my seat of depression
[Music]
your boss represents the company
if you see a boss slacking off what's
that tell you i mean heath doesn't even
dress up in a chef's jacket who am i
busting my ass for with seemingly the
weight of the world on his shoulders
frank is about to face a busy night as
word has leaked out that chef ramsay is
at dalby day
okay now have the uh veal chop
okay all the things but back in the
kitchen frank
come on it appears as though frank has
given up before dinner has even started
frank come on come on come on come on
[Music]
the only reason why i don't quit is
because i'm too proud let's go one
salmon one tag one shoot my friend
as orders continue to pile into the
kitchen i'm waiting on a duck and a
salmon i got the duck right here can i
call a table pointy please table 20. a
depressed frank tries to get motivated
what's up on table ten zap three
eggplant bags yeah i'm [ __ ] up right
now but it's not long before the kitchen
is backed up
do you know what that is
they are coming out they are coming out
the kitchen's a little bit behind
i need two fettuccine bonnets on the fly
hey anthony slow what the [ __ ] down what
do you think i'm doing shut up i know
what you want
my brother i hate his attitude i hate
working with him because like i can't
tell frank anything without him telling
me to go [ __ ] myself table 31 don't wait
in an hour shut the [ __ ] up
talk to each other if you guys say
nothing it's just like the blind leading
the blind well i think ramsay it's great
because it's like he's the only one he's
going to listen to table
10. if we listen to him i'm waiting on
32. you can't cook that fast i need
every next pocket for me from rush rush
rush what the [ __ ] is it with the
society i need two bolognese right i'm
behind ready yeah
they're going to send this back
all right start cooking another one
because they're going to send it back
this goes to table five do it now
the fish was bad that was like ah
[ __ ] let it roll that took a gamble i
mean it doesn't look pretty but they
like it they like it if not
i'm sorry this is really dry
and there's salmon on the fly table five
food drive
frank you knew that was coming back
why did you send it
he said he's gonna get a complaint
either way they're gonna wait too long
but they're gonna send it back i'd
rather they wait
and have it perfect and wait and send
[ __ ] to come back
how sad is that
[Music]
when a chef doesn't care that means the
rest goes downhill rapidly and that's
exactly what's happening tonight i think
frank is way too burnt out right now
it's more depressing than anything
unbelievable
it's an hour and a half into dinner
service
table 20 and table three that's what i'm
putting up and food is slowly making its
way out to the diners
but unfortunately it's not worth the
wait
frank
this is lukewarm yes son of a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you need a [ __ ] lemon juice [ __ ]
stupid chicken
[ __ ]
pardon me
oh not what
he says it's over done shut the [ __ ]
this is the way up is don't come back
with it
this is that this is a breaking point of
this restaurant right here
food sucks anyways not putting up
[ __ ] [ __ ]
frank needs to make a commitment to
working hard and if you don't have that
passion you don't have it and you got to
get out of here anymore [ __ ] slips
coming in
frank we're screwed i'm not [ __ ]
cooking i'm not doing it
so what you don't like it this is
lukewarm too dry he says it's over done
it may only be halfway into dinner
service it's horrible
frank we're screwed i'm not [ __ ]
cooking i'm not doing it but owner frank
has had enough
i might not go back in tonight i've
definitely lost the passion for cooking
or for being in the restaurant business
period
i don't know what to do anymore
with frank abandoning the kitchen sous
chef eddie and the rest of the staff
finish off a painful dinner service
folks thank you very much have a good
night
tonight i saw something quite
frightening
wasn't the bad food wasn't the
complaints and it certainly wasn't the
service
it was frank
and here's why
watching him he is so
burnt out
he's given up it's like a ticking time
bomb that's about to explode
i know
[Music]
i love him i've seen how much over the
years he's done for everyone
[Music]
[Music]
this is not about a guy that can't be
bothered to cook he is done he's on the
floor
and he's barely breathing
what have we done
we start by bringing him back tonight
take 10 minutes out and think of
something you've never said him before
that can help to inspire him
do you understand yes
good night good night thank you very
much
frankie's stopping but he's got a good
heart i think he thinks i'm against them
it's really not like that
you know it's my brother
i love him
but if we can't work together without a
doubt we will close the doors
[Music]
frank has clearly lost his passion
and unfortunately his family and his
business are being dragged down with
them let's uh sit down chef ramsay knows
that if this restaurant has any chance
of surviving he must find a way to
inspire frank take a seat
when i watched you last night from start
to finish it upset me and here's why i
witnessed a broken man
i could see all the stress has killed
your spirit
i spoke to kim and anthony late last
night and
they both just want to say something to
you personally
anthony i wrote it down
got a [ __ ] speech
frank we both know we're not good at
this stuff
all right
frank i think you have been so
overwhelmed for so long and for good
reason
i know how much damage i've done
[Music]
[Music]
and you had to hold it together
now i believe you need to take care of
yourself
you and i both know that you have it in
you to get back into life no matter what
we say to each other you know if it
comes down to it i'm always there
i think we lost sight of what we really
count i believe we can really make this
place work you know that we can
if we put the effort into it we don't
ever say it but i do love you
that's it
my brother's never that's the first time
i heard any remorse from him a
legitimate remorse
should i listen i should not listen
no
okay
to say i love you is an understatement
and to say that i'm always beside you i
think you know that the past 12 years
have been the hardest of our lives but
we made it through together
because we love each other and i look at
the way you talk to people lately and
the mean things that come out of your
mouth
and i think it comes from you holding
this burden for the whole family for so
long on your shoulders
you haven't put this chef jack on in
four years
because i think instead you felt you
didn't deserve it anymore but you do
you're actually one of the most talented
people i've ever met in my life
that lack of passion that showed in the
food yesterday for gordon was a cry for
help you are worth it and you deserve
success and you've worked hard for it
and you deserve it frank but the only
way this place is gonna make it is you
have to look within you and break down
this wall that you've built
please put this back on
now i'm serious
i don't deserve to wear that jacket
because schmuck could put up the food i
was putting up you don't wear a uniform
if you don't produce put it back on not
yet
after an emotional we don't ever say it
but i do love you and hopeful plea from
his family please put this back on
not yet chef ramsay goes to work
i don't care about the [ __ ] that's been
kicked into you years ago you got to
cook trying to reignite frank's passion
in the kitchen i want you to think of
something that you want to cook and put
the passion on the plate not the anger
ramsay feeling like the freaking thing
that i made yesterday i don't know what
to do to flees the guy what are you
thinking of doing oh my god it's total
blank
i hope he thinks it's good
fans say this in a simple lemongrain
wine
nice i'd like to see your mind working
you know
it means your passion's coming back
frankie he has a talent to put out that
kind of food if he gets dedicated it
could be done if not it's over before we
go to the sauce shall it's time a little
dash of rosemary
no good
it's delicious
you're always on the defensive who said
no good [ __ ] ripped me a new [ __ ]
out there if i got served that
yesterday's my entree i'd be like a
pigging [ __ ]
he liked it cooking with chef ramsay
made me feel like i was cooking it the
old days the way i had passion about
doing things absolutely delicious good
now that frank's spirit has been lifted
chef ramsay decides to go ahead with
phase two of his plan
giving a facelift to the tired decor of
davide
[Music]
good morning good morning frank how are
you ah
full nervous great
let's go
come in come in come in oh my god
look at this
they are beautiful
welcome to the new derby day right where
should we start a new modern
appeal gone are they all dreadful chairs
nice we've replaced them with stunning
new
mahogany chairs beautiful
okay take a look at this that is awesome
by replacing those dreadful white walls
above the stone we've contemporized the
dining room now we've got textured
material it's lit underneath it is going
to look absolutely beautiful and what
about the davide
sconces aren't they beautiful they are
absolutely gorgeous have a look at these
booths you know we swapped
the blanquettes
for the booze this is now a fresh
modern vibe absolutely beautiful
everything is perfect gordon we couldn't
have asked for anything more these were
things that we were never able to do
because it was so far down to death
and to see a friend cry
it's
overwhelming was everything we wanted to
do
i've been down here in this grave for 27
years now it's like totally everything
is different and modernized i can feel
it
the hope is coming
back frankie can i just say something
okay please put that away
frankie please you need to wear a chef's
coat because you're a chef take this off
and please please for me you're a chef
you're really here
the first time i wore a jacket it's four
tiers i didn't want people to know i was
the head chef back here
[Music]
it's a symbol of that you are back you
can do this because you're better than
you should have ever taste
am i the right way hey they're looking
nice to see him put on the coat
to me meant that yes i'm taking this all
seriously and it's it just means a lot
to me
and now you look like it's the chef that
you are
because you can do it
you're touching cinnamon for your wife
but jacket doesn't make the person
gives you a way to go there but it
doesn't make the person
now that frank appeared ready to command
the kitchen it's time for the final
phase of chef ramsay's plan
the menu
have a look at this wow oh my god the
future of devon day is right in front of
your eyes on the table it looks so nice
gone
are the dreadful plates of the 80s
the appetizers bruschetta roasted
peppers the cake of berries marinated
baby tomatoes burrata how could we be
a modern italian restaurant without any
burrata
then the pierce the resistance the main
course homemade gnocchi ground butter
truffle oil and some fresh chives at the
end homemade stress that every time
homemade yeah pork tenderloin frank your
chicken lemon chicken we've put onion
compote on there as well
tonight we relaunch
the modern david dig in
there's no one in a lot then
it does this new menu
awesome i am overwhelmed it's a kick-ass
menu
it tastes so much that's delicious going
for this touch change the whole menu
into what it needs to be for this type
of a city with this many restaurants and
that's what's going to set us apart from
all the others the chicken i like it
it's only an hour before dinner service
and chef ramsay has one more important
message for frank
anthony's never going to be perfect in
your eyes but
for a recovering addict to be clean for
two years that's good
it's it's not bad i wish my brother was
clean i wish he had kicked his habit
they were a similar age
and
the
crap that we go through on a daily basis
is just extraordinary but
cut him some slack
and get him by your side help him
because i think
when you start helping him he's going to
come back
10 times over
well yeah
no
maybe i've been too tough with anthony
me and anthony have to work together and
turn the restaurant around yeah of
course it's gonna be hard it's never
gonna be easy no nothing ever is if you
want it you can do it
[Music]
i know you can do it i won't let you
down
he got my passion back it's so amazing
that this is coming up
[Music]
it's relaunch night at darby day okay
show time guys and frank is already
feeling the pressure holy mary mother of
god i never felt this nervous
before i don't want to disappoint
anybody and i want to prove it to myself
i can't do it but chef ramsay has some
important information that is going to
make the evening even more intense i
just had a call would listen to me yeah
tonight you've got the boston magazine
coming in as well
tonight the steaks were raised from the
beginning so our eyes wide open yeah
and now we're gonna be boston magazines
in the restaurant and that's a big deal
i'm ready to go
tonight we change to the menu
we're going to order a bunch of
different options
right this way please
shrimp
i'll do the tuscan bread soup
with the restaurant packed foster
magazine have just arrived table they go
on 15.
the first tickets are in and frank is
about to face his first big test all
right five's coming up all the tables of
high priority
magazine it affects the business they're
quite a bad review oh that's pretty
enjoyable
[Music]
this is really good i would love the
recipe i would
while the critics from the boston
magazine are clearly pleased with their
appetizers
they aren't the only ones
delicious and for the first time in a
long time
this quaint dining room in the north end
of boston is buzzing frank a new order
just came in but back in the kitchen
expediter i need entrees on table 12
immediately okay
frank talk to each other a little bit
yeah yeah the mood is starting to turn
and the tension is building between the
brothers capellini papadella's the
second course and i got to knock into
pavilio right now as anthony pushes
frank to finish the boston magazine's
entrees keep it together come on cool
tonight yes
table 15 flank next course two ravioli
one park yes yes we start at 15. it's
very rare the boston magazine come out
like that i'll drop a hat and that
walker's working
franklin okay i got the port so i could
complete come on frankie got the other
two get me that's it don't ever rush me
come on give me give me give me enough
when it's ready get me go
thank you
that looks beautiful yeah and like wow
the cork is a little raw should we send
it back
i wanted to make a good impression oh my
god
it was a disaster table 15 wants a
footballer
[ __ ] it's the boston magazine oh my god
what's your fault frank it's gonna be
the biggest [ __ ] hole in boston in five
minutes now yeah come on the one also
came back that table that'll come back
this is a [ __ ] disaster
[Music]
it's davide's grand reopening
and a critical mistake at the boston
magazine table to rock back to park [ __ ]
it's the boston magazine
has frank's confidence completely shaken
oh my god what's your fault you got
another one going what's up
what's up
well how do you want to communicate
i let jeff ramsey down and let myself
down and let everybody down
[ __ ] off
i almost went back to the old ways but i
took a deep breath and i was like okay i
i gotta refocus here i'm not keeping up
i'm tired but i'm not giving up pull up
put that in the water
okay here you go here's the quark that
consisted we fight that's 15 take it out
come back strong yeah let's go
thank god i was trying to impress you
tonight
i'm sorry
make sure it's good
it's good
i'm kind of excited to see what happens
in the next few months here
call me something table 21 cable 23 pick
up if you two continue talking we're
gonna get there yes sir good the
relationship with anthony is still
fractured that's what's holding us back
in the restaurant but he's been trying
harder i see it so i'm willing to
compromise
with anthony supporting frank in the
kitchen
anthony nice come on guys bring it
together over there beautiful vocal
manning
for that the two brothers complete
dinner service on a high end right now
every night
[Music]
wow
what a night yeah good in bed trust me
mostly good
think back to my first day here i saw a
family in turmoil
and
a chef that was sitting down in the
kitchen depressed
but tonight
i saw a family
come together and pull off a strong
service
frank you proved to me tonight that you
can run a kitchen
the way you handled the pressure
was phenomenal yes
i feel grateful beyond words
for frankie to hear gordon say that you
can do this a hundred percent
it just means so much because he
deserves this
i can't say thank you enough
and frank
keep that
chef jacket on keep that attitude with
it
and never
sit down in a kitchen ever again
i'm rooting for your success
i'm really excited for the future my
goal now is to keep the passion going
this is a new day for darby day and i'm
gonna feel me good guys good luck yes
good luck good luck good luck and more
importantly just stay calm
that's it just thank you
[ __ ] passion of man in there with a
lot to give
okay
don't stop
i'll crack a smile from time to time
yeah
there's no words that you could describe
what i'm feeling right now it's
overwhelming
totally overwhelming
goodnight chef goodnight
thank you
[Music]
for the last 10 years boston has seemed
to ignore davide but now with a huge
turnaround with the food and the staff
it's got every right to return to his
former glory
my god
people think i've got a funny accent
jeez
in the weeks that followed frank's
rediscovered passion for cooking
flourished
i'm thinking
he's back in love with food huh i want
to make myself proud of my family crowd
and chef ramsey crowd and the city of
boston is reaping the benefits
as for his brother anthony thank you
beautiful he too has
very
made
a
see you next he is clearly committed to
the restaurant very good
thank you and more importantly to his
brother
[Music]
you